parfois les têtes tournent et les fait
tourner mal encore un film psychédélique
et présenté à la quinzaine des
réalisateurs où il a reçu le prix art et
essai sdae climax raconte une fête une
simple fait introniser par une troupe de
danseurs quelque chose à faire déraper
l'actionnaire mais je pense que rien
vous révéler derrière ce pitch très
simple digne d'un film d'horreur
le projet de gaspar noé beaucoup plus
ambitieux simon presque mystique il pose
aussi une question qu'on retrouve dans
tous ses films louis gaspar noé moi
c'est un réalisateur qui me passionne
qui me passionnait mais qui m'ennuie un
peu parce que j'avais l'impression
qu'ils se forçait à aa a fait rentrer
des normes concept dans son cinéma qui
finissait un peu par l'écraser je vais
vous raconter la mort l'amour avec love
et la région non là je vais juste vous
mettre un truc dans la sangria vous
allez voir et du court en rétrécissant
on va dire son point de départ
en réalité il reprend complètement la
maîtrise de son cinéma et il va explorer
quelque chose qui était sous jacent
vraiment sous jacent dans plusieurs de
ses films précédents on va dire c'est
l'angoissé de l'extase
qu'est ce qui se passe si j'ai trop de
plaisir qu'est ce qui se passe si le
plaisir ne s'arrête pas et si le plaisir
devenait un motif de l'horreur et ça on
va le voir dans une des toutes premières
scènes du film que je vous ai amené
alors avant qu on la lance elle a l'air
de rien on va voir un personnage se
balader parmi ses copains parmi ces
trucs on est en train de boire l'apéro
et vous allez voir combien c'est
maîtrisé évidemment la caméra ne
s'arrête pas emmener en plan séquence on
est chez gaspard noé et vous allez voir
comme même si on est content et là on
est content d'être en groupe déjà se
forment des petites entités après garder
moi je suis tout seul mais je vais
prendre deux verres de sangria parce que
j'ai bien envie de l'offrir à quelqu'un
on vient de terminer le filage de notre
de notre numéro de danse et j'ai pas
besoin de terminer la soirée tout seul
et justement il cherche ce qui va être
un des points de focales
tout le film c'est sofia boutella avant
on nous donne quelques infos le
discrètement voilà un de mes collègues
du bois pas lui il ne peut pas passer à
même sort avec les autres et là regardez
up nouvelles comme on va répartir
l'espace voici à des centres
névralgiques de la scénographie à savoir
l'endroit où on va faire d'où vient le
son et la nouveau je me promène et away
si sofia boutella c'est la personne qui
cherche depuis le début qu'il veut
absolument réussir à séduire qui me
plaît énormément
et là on va nous indiquer tout de suite
qu'on va pas rester tout le temps ici il
ya un autre monde qui attend derrière où
la lumière les différentes ce sont les
coulisses ils sont encore fermés mais la
sangria va petit à petit vers son effet
et ce monde va s'ouvrir
mais c'est un tout tout de suite cette
séquence ne viennent quasiment une bande
annonce qui nous dit regardez tout ce
qui est prêt à arriver au nom mais on ne
veut pas on veut pas on peut pas encore
c'est lui en veut pas entendre d'achat
tous les éléments sont là pour exploser
il ya ce qu'il faut d'amitié de tension
vous remarqué que la caméra ne s'est pas
arrêtée qu'on s'est promené au milieu de
ce groupe d'humains sans discontinuer
c'est d'une maîtrise discrète qui est
absolument affolante qu'y at-il dans la
sangria certainement pas les vies bloom
qui vous jetez votre amie clare and on
attendait qui se construit dans ce cas
la gueule pas moi qui vais demander un
geste posé la question
c'est à willy de commencer du coup bah
moi en fait alors je vais mettre quand
même je vais dire juste avant moi je
trouve que c'est un génie visuel mais
dans ce film là il ya quand même quelque
chose qui m'a frappé déjà alors gaspar
noé il fait des coûts il fait des
braquages cinéma est là pour la première
fois c'est quand même un symptôme qui
devrait nous éclairer toute la critique
est pratiquement unanimes sur le film
pour quelqu'un qui veut choquer c'est un
petit peu emmerdant et moi ce film là je
trouve que c'est un climax dans le sens
où un instantané de son cinéma ça dit on
voit à la fois toutes ces qualités
visuelles et d'un seul coup l'absence de
fonds la bêtise de fonds dans 5 le fond
c'est la forme le confirme c'est pas
bien sûr que si c'est pas pour rien
qu'ils sont devant devant une image bleu
blanc rouge et qu'on a cette espèce de
groupe et ça a été rajouté un peu malade
mais anecdotique c'est pas ça qui me
dérange c'est pourquoi il
voilà il ne dépasse pas voilà il y avait
un formidable brouillon pourquoi il se
dit pas au lieu d'aller frimer à cannes
se dire je vais reprendre ça et je veux
en faire un chef-d'oeuvre ça manque de
littérature samoa pas de littérature ça
ne parle que des cordes comment ils
interagissent comment ils n'arrivent pas
interagir
jamais se rassembler ces deux les purs
au contraire c'est par pure de nancy
n'est plus un côté même night is l'on
retrouve tous les motifs de de noé
jusqu'à la nausée
au final qu'est ce que ça raconte pas
grand chose il ya des moments de se
mettre ensemble même quand on prend son
pied moi je trouve ça génial
et en plus le film à la politesse d'être
hilarant je me marre ça tient peut-être
rémois jeu tout cas des choses gratuites
alors autant un côté un peu ado devant
ces jeux vidéo mais froid non moi ça me
manque situ ou la porte des enfers va
ouvrir là vraiment il ya littérature
dessus si tu fous en enfant dans un film
pareil
très bien alors essaye de me choquer
avait coulé de fait il n'a pas gagné
quelle est ta fait pour cet enfant mais
moi je gagne je l'aimé je les trouvais
de déduire un mémoire de ceux qui sont
morts c'est intéressant parce qu'on a
une intrusion dans le duel intrusion du
mari uns comme une manne à la parole
alors bizarrement moins que ça dans ma
vie mais c'est parce que tu sais quoi
ce qui chagrine moi même avoir cru
cinéma de gaspar noé dont je trouve
comme toi que c'est un réalisateur
génial est rien ce qu'ils racontent ne
m'interesse jamais hélas oui tu cette
mémoire c'est la modestie des trucs vous
êtes justement qu'il n'y a pas d'espèces
de pseudo littérature de j'ai 14 ans je
vais vous expliquer ce que c'est l'amour
parce que quand il fait ça j'ai envie de
me buter or là justement il ya une
espèce de modestie de films de genre
d'abord il ya par exemple qu'il ya des
séquences de danse extraordinaire je
n'ai pas vu ça au cinéma depuis bien il
aime la danse comme personne la phase
aller 3 2 me pour dominer la table at on
rappelé ça fait 1 5 ans ça fait cinq ans
qu'on voit sofia boutella dans des rôles
d'extraterrestres de cascadeuse dans
kingman et on voit qu'elle a un talent
un charisme des droits n'a jamais rien
eu à jouer et bien là tout va dans celui
où tu me dis bah y'a rien et bah tu
rigoles c'est le film où son talent est
incroyable elle crève l'écran car il
philippe even la france rff va les
régler
non mais vas-y vas-y
non mais c'est de la fatigue ou de la
fin ce film est à clyde bac c'est à dire
que il ya le plus beau des plans
séquences que vous aurez vu cette année
et à ce moment là le film redémarre et
le film ne raconte pas rien le film
raconte ce que tu dis la difficulté
d'être ensemble
même dans la joie et on en ressort avec
le plaisir d'être vivant et ça c'est pas
tous les jours qu'on a ça au cinéma qui
a raison qui a tort climax de gaspar noé
et au cinéma allez-y en dansant mais
allez-y sobrement
si vous avez plus de 16 ans est revenu
me dire ce que vous en pensez sur les
réseaux sociaux par exemple où nous
lisons je lis tout ce que vous nous
écrivez